we have just received confirmation from
meridian that on October 27 2560 spartan
117 the man most commonly known as the
master chief died in the line of duty
the master chief is dead at least that's
according to the latest trailer for halo
5 Guardians now for any fan of halo this
is almost impossible to believe because
he has survived so much and in fact done
so much in the Halo universe for
Humanity in fact the whole galaxy so
what better way to celebrate him in
death and to look back at his
achievements in life exactly how many
times did the Master Chief save humanity
let's find out
ah
the Master Chief's legendary exploits
began in 2552 where not only defeated
the Covenant a race of aliens bent on
the faith-based cleansing of humanity
but he halted an infestation of the
flood a race of creatures more plague
than beasts not a bad start this all
took place upon the first halo ring
these circular structures were created
by a race called the forerunners the
Rings are a last resort of defense
against the biggest danger in the galaxy
the aforementioned plague like flood why
a last resort well you see an activated
halo ring combats the flood by
eliminating their food source smart the
only problem is is that their food
source is all sentient life yeah bit
drastic well thankfully rather than
activating it the Master Chief destroyed
the first halo ring along with the
Covenant and the flood remaining there
saving all life in the galaxy chalk one
up to the chief station alert Home Fleet
immediately they found us the Covenant
they found
our hero didn't get much time to relax
however not long after the Covenant
managed to find earth and attempted an
invasion while the United Nations space
commander UNSC repelled most of the
assault one enemy ship commanded by a
covenant high-profit broke through and
attacked the city of New Mombasa Kenya
not only the chief help repel the attack
and clear the city of covenant horses he
also chased the high profit through
slipspace only to wind up at another
halo ring what exactly am I looking at
that another hand chief saved everyone
by again halting the activation of the
halo installation although he did have
some help this time around from a former
covenant turned a lie the arbiter and a
bunch of his friends and of course
helpful AI Cortana no I don't want to
chance a remote detonation I need to
stay here
unfortunately though during the shutdown
of this halo ring failsafe was triggered
causing all the other halo rings
throughout the galaxy to be put on
standby and a bit making them all
activatable from some remote location
somewhere known as the ark not ideal but
still a hero once more you mind telling
me what you're doing on that ship sir
finishing this fight although one small
problem you see the Covenant believed
the ark to be located on earth and still
hell-bent on activating the halo rings
and wiping out humanity they brought the
fight back to Planet Earth so once again
mankind had to lean on the Master Chief
to save them this time he helped repel
the attack before following the Covenant
back through a slipspace portal now
leading directly to the ark located far
beyond the edges of the Milky Way galaxy
that's our galaxy were beyond the rim
change to the 80 light-years from
galactic center to be precise what is
this place the young this is the arc I
had always assumed it was part of a
shield installation but it seems I was
mistaken that's a first hot on their
heels there was a ship full of flood who
began to infest the ark luckily along
with the ark chief also discovered a
halo ring under construction I would be
replacement for the one he destroyed a
few years earlier given the growing
infestation of the flood and the massive
distance between their location and any
other life he decided to activate the
ring this time around in order to wipe
the max and save the galaxy for a third
time however as he made his bid for
escape the ring self destruction caused
the slipspace portal to collapse
transporting only half of the ship back
to earth the path without the master
chief who now had to sit in cryostasis
for a while as a reward for saving the
day wake me
when you need me
you
four years later Master Chief is a
walk-in from stasis only to have to save
everyone and everything all over again
this time the threat came from the
makers of the halo rings in the first
place the forerunners
after crashing down on a forerunner
planet the Master Chief had to battle an
ancient forerunner warrior called the
Didact a race of mechanical a I called
the Prometheans and the Covenant all at
once he eventually succeeded though
destroying the Didact ship with a
nuclear bomb but losing his best friend
the AI Cortana in the process we
sacrificed herself to save him wait John
but now after saving the human race and
all other sentient life on four separate
occasions the master chief is dead we
don't know how or even why and this
obviously raise these questions about
who we will be playing as in Halo 5 and
also how the Halo universe will survive
without him I think these questions
though are for another day for now we
should just remember and celebrate one
of video games most prolific heroes hail
to the chief
you